What is the meaning of the word toba?
And both in general terms I want to know
it and in the Islamic context please.
The Arabic word Toba
literally means
to return or to come back. And in the
Islamic context in the Sharia, it means
a person who leaves the things which
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala has prohibited
and he returns back to the things which
Allah subhanana wa tala has commanded.
So in short it means a person leaving
the acts which Allah has prohibited and
he returns back to the acts which Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala has commanded and
this aspect of Toba or repentance is
present in all the religions that
believe in the concept of God and Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala speaks about Toba
and repentance in the Quran in several
places including surah chapter number 24
verse number 31 where Allah says, "Oh
you who believe, turn allto together in
repentance to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
so that you may attain bless." Allah
repeats a similar message in surah bakra
chapter number two verse number 222
where Allah says that Allah loves those
who turn to him in repentance and Allah
loves those who are clean and pure.
And a similar message is given in the
hadith of our beloved prophet wasallam.
It's mentioned in say bkari
volume number 8 book of applications had
number 6309 where our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is more pleased when
his servant seeks repentance than any
one of you when he finds his camel which
has been lost in the desert. That means
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is very
pleased when anyone seeks his
repentance, asks for forgiveness and he
forgives them. So in short, tba means
repentance which means leaving the act
which is pri Allah subhanaa tala and
returning back to the acts which he has
commanded. In short, it's a journey from
the dislike to the thing which is liked
by Allah subhanaa tala.